[Musik]
wir befinden uns hier am hochgebirgsland
wehrgang 2020 teil winter
dieser lehrgang wird zwei mal im jahr
durchgeführt von der pflegerin
fliegerabwehr truppen schule im rahmen
des militärpiloten lehrgang ist ein 2
dieser dient dazu um die einsatzpiloten
des bundesheers vorzubereiten auf b1
die möglichen einsätze im hochgebirge
[Musik]
und 26 die faszination für spleen war
bei mir grundsätzlich immer der wunsch
der fans werden ist war recht spät
kommen erst gegen ende meiner zeit wo
ich vor der frage abgelaufen ist ohne
zivildienst ungefähr entschieden und so
habe ich ausgeglichen und sagt ja wenn
ich die bundesregierung wird definitiv
das ist auch immer war ich bin dann 2016
und september ein blick unter spiele
gemacht und wartet und nach dessen
nämlich geworden und erst dann noch ca
haben ja wo das verfahren auch schon im
vollen gange war noch den
psychologischen und medizinischen tests
noch zeit ich gekommen bin
wichtig ist mir dass weg machen will ist
an beim thema wird völlig egal ob das
auto brannte es dann darum was ist eine
schwere und man muss schauen dass man
alles gibt dann bleiben und sie warten
lassen
[Musik]
das einfach beworben bietet diese
hochgebirgs lange leer kam natürlich die
möglichkeit dass wir deswegen gebilde
konzentriert liegen können deswegen in
größeren höhen insbesondere stellen uns
vor spezielle herausforderungen zum
einen ist die luftdichte dort geringer
das wirkt sich auf die privatleistung
aus und habe auch ergonomisch einflüsse
das heißt da unterm strich aber in
größeren höhen nicht mehr so
leistungsfähig und speziell das
versuchen wir in diesem lehrgang zu
trainieren
weiters kommt natürlich dazu dass wir
dort auch ortskenntnisse gewinnen das
haben wir zuletzt unter beweis stellen
können
beim assistenzeinsatz schnee letztes
jahr 2000
[Musik]
die
der anstifter 50er ich finde seinen
warmen worten ausbildung der lehrer 2000
berg
minute jetzt fliegen wir vorher nochmal
dfb gebraucht und wofür ich mich aktuell
zum bundestag kommen jetzt auswahl
feuerwehr im rahmen
[Musik]
[Applaus]